[Music]
and let's welcome our final speaker
brandon graham
from children's hospital in philadelphia
who's going to talk about shiny new
things
and using r to bridge the gap in um emr
reporting
um so hi um i'm brendan graham and i'm a
clinical data analyst at chop um today
i'm going to be talking about a project
kind of centered on scheduling hospital
admissions
and how i used r not only to kind of
explore and analyze the data
but to develop new and useful kind of
workflow tools um that are being used
every day in the hospital
they kind of go above and beyond like
the reporting capabilities
of the electronic medical records
software um
so before i get started this is the
medical room so i'm going to quiz
everybody um
like why do we need to focus on hospital
admissions so like kind of by show of
hands
who here kind of thinks that hospitals
kind of are operating optimally around
like 60
capacity show fan 70
occupancy 80
90. i see a few hands what about like
100 occupancies like the ideal occupancy
that's not is that optimal
so um really the kind of the range is
really like we think of it as like 80 to
85
optimal you know you always want some
excess capacity to be able to handle
like an influx of of patients
if you need to so with that in mind
here's kind of what chops uh hospital
occupancy is kind of looking like over
the last few years um
at the monthly level with that optimal
range kind of shaded in
so this is kind of why we're focusing on
projects around hospital admissions
um and you know nine out of the last 12
months we've been operating at or above
90
occupancy um in the hospital and so what
the data is showing us and what people
are really feeling
is like this new this high occupancy is
really like our new norm
and we kind of need to do a better job
of like managing our capacity given this
like sustained increase
in the demand for the services so as
you know operating at such a high
occupancy really impacts lots of areas
around the hospital i kind of don't
need to go through all of them as we're
all probably familiar with these but
to address these we have a whole series
of
projects under our capacity management
portfolio in terms of focusing on
operational ways we can
help manage our capacity and the one
i'll be talking about today is really
focused on understanding our elective
surgical admissions
and the goal of this project is really
to find ways that we can use data right
now to help operational leaders plan for
these high occupancy days ahead of time
and act if they need to so
just in case anyone's not familiar with
sort of hospital lingo here so a
hospital admission
is really just like a visit where a
patient spends one or more night in the
hospital
and so by you can probably guess by
extension a surgical admission
is a visit where a patient comes to the
hospital for surgery
and then spends one or more night and we
do have sort of non-surgical admissions
as well but those are out of the scope
of this work
so if you have a surgical admission we
can classify that as sort of an
emergency admission meaning
you know the patient had to have
emergency surgery that required an
admission so think think of like you
know
getting your appendix removed or fixing
a broken arm things like that um
but we also have like the other
classification of these elective or
scheduled procedures
so these would be things like you know
scheduling a knee surgery for next month
or you know scheduling your um your
child
to get their tonsils removed in the
summer when they're out of school
and so we're kind of focusing on these
elective surgical admissions because we
think
since these are being scheduled and not
as urgent we should be able to do a
better job of scheduling when these are
happening
given our like capacity constraints that
i mentioned earlier
and so we kind of dove into the data and
what we saw was that the surgical
admissions are like highly variable
and this high variability really can
exacerbate a lot of the issues i
mentioned before
like looking at august of 2019 we had
one day where we had 10
surgical admissions and a different day
in that month where we had almost three
times that amount
and so you can imagine if you're like an
operational leader you know we have like
flow facilitators that are managing
like how patients are moving through the
hospital a day with 10 admissions
feels a lot different than a day with 30
especially when the units are already
really full
and so we kind of made this our mission
to like
understand the causes of this surgical
admission variability
and try to find ways to maybe contain or
minimize it or make it a little bit more
smooth a little bit more predictable so
that we can really help
with some of the capacity constraints
so since we're looking at scheduled
admissions we thought we should jump
into how things are being scheduled
and the scheduling process so i'm not
sure if this is familiar
to some of you at your institutions but
at chop surgical scheduling is like
highly decentralized
so what that means is within the
department of surgery we have several
subspecialties so general surgery
orthopedics urology neurosurgery
so on each of those subspecialties has a
group of schedulers who are scheduling
for those surgeons and those surgeons
only and their real concern is feeling
that that surgeon's our time
and there's not a real good mechanism to
kind of calibrate
what people are scheduling in terms of
admissions across all of these surgical
divisions
kind of even if they wanted to that tool
didn't exist in in the medical record or
outside of the medical record and so
as part of this work we were thinking
you know we have access to all of this
the scheduled data like we can make an
app that shows across all the divisions
what's being scheduled and presented to
people in a way
that can highlight potentially
problematic days in the future
and so to that end we developed our
scheduled admissions app so now for the
first time in
in the institution our scheduled
surgical admission volume is now
exposed across across the hospital and
is available for anyone to see
um so how this is sort of oriented is
like each facet you're seeing there each
kind of group is a month
and each row is a different unit so the
top row there is our main surgery
inpatient unit
and the lower row is our pick you our
intensive care unit
each cell and every cluster is a
calendar so each cell
is a day and the number in each cell if
you can see i know it's kind of hard to
see but
each cell is numbered and that number
represents the number of scheduled
surgical admissions for that day for the
next four months
and we were able to color code the cells
based on a combination of kind of the
historical average for that month
and also um kind of a relevant
operational threshold
so our picu's like a special case where
it's like very full
and so we wanted to be alerted earlier
for potentially problematic days so that
threshold is actually
much lower than like what sort of the
average would be
so the idea is a scheduler can use this
tool when they're scheduling
to be able to see maybe a good or a bad
day to schedule a patient and remember
the goal here is to really minimize that
variability so in an ideal state we
would never have
like a green day and then a red day and
then a green day like we kind of all
want it to be as smooth as possible
and so the app um is interactive you can
kind of hover over each day to see the
actual dates
that you're looking at and if you're
scheduling for a surgeon who only
operates like on wednesdays
you can filter just to see the
wednesdays and all of the other days
sort of disappear and all the noise is
gone and you can see
like what do the wednesdays in the next
four months look like
um you can see like where there might be
gaps in the schedule that you maybe want
to fill in or
red days that you'd maybe want to avoid
and so i'll get kind of into the impact
and kind of how this all played out but
first i want to kind of talk about how
we built this app
why we built this app in r and kind of
how we kind of use
the electronic medical record data at
chop to go from
you know the the medical record itself
to into r
so you know every day you have the
schedulers who are scheduling in the
medical record itself
and then every night all of that data
goes into our data warehouse
not only the schedule the scheduled data
but all of like the hospital data for
that day
goes into our data warehouse um and
as an analyst we're writing sql queries
against that data warehouse to build up
sort of
um the data set that you need for an
analysis in my case
i need to know the scheduled surgical
admissions for the next four months by
unit
and you know by day um and so our data
engineers
at shop have um set up apache airflow
which we kind of use as like analyst
owned etl
and this lets analysts um at chop who
are
sort of the content experts create and
own data marts in the data warehouse
with little to no data engineer
involvement
and so airflow kind of runs my scheduled
admission sql query every morning
and then creates a table in the data
warehouse of just those results for me
so every day this is updating for the
next four months it's sort of like a
rolling table
and so that table now exists in the data
warehouse as its own like standalone
table
and that's the table that i that i bring
into our it's like almost set up it has
all the raw data that i need and just
the data i need
um but i need to bring it into r to kind
of organize it a little bit and get it
ready to present
so i bring it into our studio and i use
a combination of
some tidy verse packages namely like d
plier and lubridate
as well as the rocky package which none
of you have ever heard of and i'll get
into that in a sec
to kind of organize and get the data
ready um the app i showed earlier was
actually a flex dashboard
which is kind of just like a fancy r
markdown document with some shiny under
the hood powering the reactivity
and it kind of provides us like a nice
simple layout for everyone to use
um all of the charts that you that you
saw were made with the high charter
package
it's a really great package for creating
interactive charts in r it's like
they're very sharp and very snappy and
they look great like right out of the
box
and that's allows the reactivity with
that hovering tool tip i showed you can
kind of customize that
and they're actually heat maps just
designed to look like calendars and
we're able to kind of discretely color
code in
the days kind of using that heat map
style
and then finally it's published on our
studio connect which allows anyone in
the institution with like
the link to go to the app and see what
this is
and so to get into rocky i couldn't come
to our studio and not talk about rocky
which is chop's internal package that we
developed to help us gather
explore analyze and present data and
it's called rocky because
the office that i'm in used to be called
the office of clinical quality
improvement or ocqi
and then we had r o c q i and then rocky
and then we're based in philly and then
the rocky thing
just kind of snowballed and it's called
rocky
um and we have a nice little hex sticker
there with uh with our rocky holding up
the queue
so like i said it's available to anyone
in the organization and it's like really
easy
to install we have it hosted on a cran
like repository within shop
so that we don't have to install it from
github we just have we edited everyone's
our profiles to kind of point to this
repository to install which is great
so how did i use that in this specific
instance well i really just used it to
get the data
from our cdw to r so before
if you're kind of familiar with getting
data from databases you kind of have to
do a few steps right you have to set
your connection you have to like
reference your sql file you have to
execute the sql file you have to
disconnect from the database and then
you can start doing all of your stuff
with rocky and specifically the run sql
file that we implemented all of that
sort of abstracted away from the
analysts
and i just have to remember one function
and where i saved the file
and this is great for like a couple
reasons um
you know as a new hire coming in you
don't have to have all of these steps
that you're
as you're learning everything else and
then you have to learn these like little
steps to connect the database we kind of
abstract all that away
and secondly there's no more passing
around this like sacred connection
string from user to user
or from yourself copying and pasting it
from document to document right it's
like
just one function to remember it's very
easy so
this is the end of my rant but if you
have like the time i definitely
recommend like developing in our package
internally to help solve some of these
like
institutional or like administrative
problems um
so kind of getting back to the app so
why did we use r for this and not like
the medical record software itself
um so the medical record software might
be kind of preferred because it's in the
scheduler's workflow
like they're in that software doing
their work but
it's kind of a closed environment and we
can't develop in there easily or quickly
it would require like outside we require
outside resources of the other
developers time
but with r you know we can do this quick
iterative tests of change and invite
the users to the table and do this sort
of design thinking approach where we're
kind of asking how do you guys want to
see it
and the other great thing is if it turns
out not to be useful we don't mind just
walking away from it because it was very
quick and easy to start up and you can
imagine starting a whole
big development project with outside
resources and then halfway through
saying actually never mind like that's
not going to feel great
but with this because our startup costs
are so low we can get things up and
running and then
you know quickly pivot if it's not
working out so the other good
reasons we did this in our is that we
have full control you know we can
have control as on rcdr studio connect
in terms of who can access it
what it looks like so the app in its
final version that i showed you it
looked nothing like that at the start
but because we invited the schedulers to
come and look at it we kind of got their
feedback and we were able to make some
changes
and finally it kind of serves now as a
single source of information we don't
have any like more conflicting reports
um that people may be generating
themselves in the medical record
you know you can inadvertently be
filtering for things you're not aware of
and you know data doesn't quite match up
and
it's it kind of solves that problem um
so as far as like the impacts of the app
so remember like before this app there
wasn't really a place to see this
information in one place and and now
there is
and while our initial audience really
was like the surgical schedulers and at
the point of scheduling
um we had other like operational leaders
like medical directors and nurse
managers kind of picking up on this
and finding it useful um these were
these were like leaders who were used to
seeing things maybe
24 to 48 hours in advance kind of this
very near-term planning
but now they're able to see at least the
surgical admissions you know up to four
months in advance
and it kind of took on life as this new
like early warning system
so now rather than trying to um maybe
influence how things are being scheduled
we're showing like these the decision
makers how things are
already scheduled and having them react
to it to be able to kind of plan for
potentially high admission
or you know high occupancy days ahead of
time um and this became kind of apparent
um one day last may i started to get
emails
from these from a nurse managers and
medical directors at the period medical
director saying you know
we have a day two weeks from now where
we have 22 admissions to the floor
which is like way too high and we need
to start thinking about rescheduling
or maybe canceling some cases which is
like a big deal we never want to do that
you never want to cancel an elective
case especially for like capacity
reasons like
that's not even like a medical reason to
reschedule something which is like
we never want to do that but if we have
to do that
we should probably be doing it as far in
advance as we possibly can
it's better to do it two weeks in
advance than two days in advance even
though obviously we never want to do it
um so i was like sure i can get you this
data here's a patient list here are
those 22 patients
here's their you know here's the
surgeon's doing it have your
you can now start the conversations do
stuff and so they were able to kind of
tweak that day and then i started
thinking
well that's happened once it's probably
going to keep happening and i should set
up a system so that i'm not sort of
responding to these
as their as these days are coming up so
to kind of get around that
um and to do that i scheduled these
dynamic emails with r
and so basically based on a threshold an
email gets sent off to these operational
leaders with a patient list
for these problematic high occupancy
days so that if they need to take action
they can
and so it kind of gives them the
information when they need it and only
when they need it
um so there's an example here with some
of the patient information blacked out
but you know it's very simple it's just
the pd
um it's an html document that's attached
to an email says here's the patients for
this day
and it just gives them the information
to act if they need to
and so kind of between this email and
the app i showed we have
these operational leaders really making
like daily operational decisions
using these like workflow tools that we
made with in r
and i think it really highlights the
fact that r is more than just um you
know
an analysis kind of language or you know
for modeling like you can really make
workflow tools that are used every day
and it's been really kind of rewarding
to have people use this stuff
so why did we use r for the emails well
really it's all about the conditional
sending of the email so there's a code
chunk on the screen
um the very end of my script there's
just a simple if statement that checks
if
if there's data in a table and that
table above was basically says if a
threshold is met
show me the patience if it wasn't met
show me nothing so
if that table has data in it we send the
email and if we don't we just suppress
sending the email and that's that's it
it's really simple to set up
and with with connect it's really simple
to kind of schedule this so this is an
example of like the scheduling pane so i
just schedule the
the report to refresh daily and i send
the email after the update and that's
sort of it
and so i hear that people are using this
a lot and there was a day where we had
eight admissions to the picu which
was like wasn't going to happen so they
were able to use this
this this email to identify who those
patients were in they were able to
successfully reschedule two of them
ahead of time which kind of made that
day flow like a lot easier
um so kind of for like big takeaways
here
um i think as we all know but it's
really highlighted in some of this work
is that like r really allowed us to have
this fast iteration and user testing
um and while the initial audience was
those surgical schedulers and we were
really trying to like narrow down that
variability
um we didn't really have sort of like
the tools
to or a parallel process outside of that
app to really like
provide a lot of governance to that and
make that really stick and that
sort of this project really highlighted
that like who's in charge of saying like
no
like that wasn't obvious before this and
this kind of brought that to light like
if we have more admissions than we want
like who makes that call is it surgery
is it anesthesia is it you know hospital
operations like
what do we do here so that was kind of a
bad and good thing that came out of this
app and we're actually circling back to
address that now
um these workflow tools are really
allowing people to take
action and make decisions um because for
the first time all of this information
is kind of
exposed throughout the hospital um and
what i'm finding is like seeing this
data in this new way this like long time
horizon is now leading to the kind of
new questions being asked of the data um
we're seeing the schedule now four
months in advance and we're thinking
how can we take what we're seeing and
schedule new admissions in a way that
really does smooth that variability out
um and then to to that end and to the
the next steps here really about
intentionally scheduling things
you know and to do that we think we need
to be able to try to be able to predict
some sense of like have some sense of
the future hospital occupancy
um both the scheduled and the emergency
merchant population
uh we need to align all the scheduling
processes which are very different
between surgical and non-surgical
and then we think if we can do all of
that we can almost provide like a
recommend recommendation system to the
schedulers
for like the quote best day to schedule
that admission
from an operations point of view and
then there's obviously lots of other
things to consider you know
is the patient available is a surgeon
available doesn't need to happen within
a certain window
but we think as a starting point like we
definitely have the opportunity
to provide some decision support to the
schedulers
using all of all of the all this data
that we now have access to
and i've been showing people so you know
fingers crossed but maybe next year i'll
be back here talking about
the results of this project so um thank
you for
coming and if you have any questions and
also we're hiring so come find me
afterwards if you are interested in
joining the team thank you thank you
so we do have a number of questions
first
from matt given that the occupancy is
highly variable
does the historical data provide a
relatively conviction
consistent picture year over year
i mean there's definitely some seasonal
patterns in terms of like we have
the surgical and the medical populations
are kind of flipped so high surgical is
like very high in the summer time
because
we're at children's hospitals the kids
are off school they're having all their
elective procedures then
um it kind of dips in the winter but at
the flip side the flu season
sign of speak peaking in the winter so
there is definitely some seasonal and
like year-over-year
like larger longer-term trends but day
to day it is very variable
so nick asks in high is high occupancy
important in the picu and are there
departments
where you don't want to see high
occupancy
for example it could be an indicator of
something else that's wrong
i don't know i think we we never really
want a unit to be
fully maxed out you always want some
wiggle room um as far as something else
going on
i think there's definitely some
opportunity to look at has there been
changes in like the length of stay for
any certain population or procedure
in each unit and that's something we're
considering too when we're thinking
about like
scheduling patients in the future is
like thinking about length of state so
that's something we'll definitely have
to look into
so steven asked given that surgical
scheduling is highly decentralized
how do you incentivize or force surgical
schedulers to use your app in their
workflows
good question um you have to get
somebody
really important involved
uh it is hard it's really hard um i
think
for better or worse we never really had
to think about it until now because now
we're so packed we have to start making
these decisions so
this this um the lack of governance was
sort of hidden behind the fact that
we never kind of needed to worry about
it in the past but now that we do it's
kind of forcing
us to deal with it for sure so uh
gabriel asked do you adjust for length
of surgery
and ortho surgery can last 12 plus hours
others can be much shorter
we need to know how many hours of
surgery are scheduled
that's a good point i think when it
comes to to suggesting a day
to have the case you have to make sure
that there is a
there's the or time available for sure
so like uh
uh like a like i don't know like ear
tubes like take very short but like
orthopedic surgeries take very long so
you have to
factor in not only the patient
availability and the surgeon
availability but like
that time and the projected length of
state so there's lots of
definitely lots of things we need to
think about for sure
tiffany has a technical question here is
there a way to have a connect
r studio plus jupiter authenticate the
uh lms a canvas via lti for example
similar to jupiter hub i don't know many
of those words so i don't know
i'm sorry well
it wasn't just me
all right um so last question does
rescheduling happen very often for
surgeries
not often um and when it does it's
usually
because of like a medical reason um
the patient's sick they they maybe ate
food too close to the surgery we have to
reschedule it
so we do track the reasons why cases are
being rescheduled
um and so that's actually one of the
things we want to use that sort of like
a metric here is like how often are we
are we canceling or rescheduling cases
due to capacity reasons specifically
so luckily we do have the ability to
track that um so it doesn't happen often
but
when it does we are able to at least
know why so well thank you well let's
thank brandon
and all of our speakers